hey everybody it's billy porter and i'm
here with buzzfeed
answering your burning questions
what was your biggest takeaway from
narrating equal
my big takeaway was that i can do
narration it was nice to learn
about lgbtq history before snowball
before 1969.
equal focuses on the movement before
stone ball and that was really
informative information who is one of
your unsung lgbtq heroes bayard rustin
bayard rustin
was one of the architects of the civil
rights movement
he was the man who put that march on
washington together
he is the man that taught martin luther
king jr about non-violent
resistance the non-violent movement
civil rights movement and he was put out
because he was gay black people at the
time thought that gay and black weren't
the same thing and he needed to have a
seat
what was your first pride event like so
i was 19 years old and i
showed up i was doing joseph in the
amazing technicolor dream code at
montclair state new jersey
and the chorus boys invited me to gay
pride i arrived
in front of st patrick's on fifth avenue
and 50th street across from saks fifth
avenue my friend michael del bianco
pulled me into the line threw a t-shirt
over my head
that says silence equals death and we
started marching down the street in a
group
chanting act up fight back fight aids
pride is a riot honey what was your
first thought when you found out you
were the first openly gay black man to
win an emmy for lead actor in a drama
i was right i win everybody told me that
my queerness was my liability and i
would never have mainstream crossover
success
unless i butched it up my masculinity
was always in question
so i win i did it anyway being myself
um and i hope that gives inspiration to
other people to be themselves as well
that's the only thing we got what is the
best part about playing pray tell on
pillows
the fact that he's three dimensional a
real fully fleshed out human being
being fabulous has not always been
synonymous with also being serious
what has been your favorite red carpet
outfit to date
i would have to say the oscar tuxedo
dress is my favorite because
it is the moment that launched it all
what are you most excited about
playing the fairy godmother in the
remake of cinderella i'm just excited
that i'm playing the whitney houston
park i like to say that and i'm gonna
keep saying it
that's exciting my favorite memory
shooting taylor swift you need to come
down video
the fact that we had to shoot it because
of my schedule
on a green screen in a studio in
brooklyn
i never even met her until afterwards if
you could sing
a duet with any iconic singer in history
who would it be
whitney houston where do you keep your
emmy grammy and tony
in my living room and where will you put
your oscar beside all four of those
what did you love most about performing
kinky boots on broadway
all of it you know once again it was
finally fabulous
and serious at the same time in the role
of lola
those two things can co-exist favorite
date night with your
husband i love just sitting on sofa and
cooking dinner and
having quiet time what's a role you hope
to play one day
something that i create myself not sure
what that is but i want to create it
myself
who would you want to play you in a
movie about your life
i'm really not sure that person is
around yet i don't know yet what's a
hidden talent
most people don't know you have i can
cook i could could too
on top of them the best in the town what
has been the most challenging scene to
shoot and pose
the love scene i was 49 years old when i
shot that
and being a person whose masculinity has
been up and
been in question since the moment i
could comprehend thought you know i was
never masculine
enough to be the object of anybody's
affection in
anything ever so i didn't know how to
engage that way
and it really freaked me out what did
you want to be when you grew up exactly
what i'm doing favorite broadway
show to watch as a fan and why
i would have to say it would be hamilton
and um
once again what i love about it is it
puts
people of color inside of real human
characters telling
real human stories with
three-dimensional human beings
i love that and i also love you know the
effect that what i call the hamilton
effect which is
uh speaking to this idea of immigration
and that
america is built on the spirit of
immigration we are all
immigrants except the indigenous people
of america who this country was stolen
from
that's why i like watching hamilton
thank you everybody for spending some
time with me
and please tune in to equal on hbo max
when it comes out in october god bless
[Music]
you
you